I was obsessed yesterday with fafa
phooey and that
busting him on eating those plantain
chips first of all he's mad at everyone
but everytime he gets on air I'm gonna
say nine times out of ten he's the
middlee eating something is a constant
food orgy going on back there you talk
to me
changeup I've just been handed a note
that Gary has a huge bowl of plantain
chips
it's a plantation Gary's all upset cuz
Jason told on him about the plantain
chips Gary you yelling at Jason he's
just reporting he was angry with Jason
oh my goodness he was out of his mind I
was wrong about the eating I totally
admit that I don't like people going in
my office I look at through my stuff
this has nothing to do with what I was
eating I don't think he looked through
your stuff I think your bowl of plantain
chips was not on your dad's office he
went into my office to see what was
going on in there my office is
off-limits but you'd office door was
open and all but he walked in how could
he avoid he wanted to see what with the
bullet it wasn't like reading what you
were reading I'd you see I was making a
joke to drive him nuts but I did not
actually go through his drawers try he
he first of all I don't mean while Gary
was so mad at you he stopped the eating
burping I don't waste calories by
walking I leaned over and looked in his
office from my chair he's got a big
giant tub of plantain chips on it yeah
how do you miss that
no I was already out of your office I
was out of your office when you scream
across an entire office day the [ __ ] out
of your office I was already out of your
office thing and by the way I'm not
staying out of your office we're filming
a radio show we're doing something here
your doors wide open it's not your
office calm the [ __ ] down
no it's not if you're on the air and
you're eating and I'm
if my office is my office I said I'm
look at your office right now the whole
world is look at it allows you to see if
you don't want people looking at your
office go sit upstairs oh you're funny
Jason I can tie this all set upstairs
you're either part of it or you're not
dude
you don't look at my desk I mean the
show is a reality show sorts where get
over yourself and you owe me an apology
you scream at me in the office yesterday
like a maniac everything Jesus Christ
I'll show you I need Jesus they didn't
go looking on his computers a big giant
[ __ ] tub of food sitting on a desk
with a camera in front of it was a giant
of a plant a nub this is one of 50
different food items you have when will
you go get more plantains Gary
I swear Gary's drawers like Trader Joe's
right that's why I know you're really
mad about something else because this
isn't about the show accepted thank you
Gary and I do not realize that plantain
was over-the-line and I what do you
think I feel bad about seeing plantains
on your desk of course something that's
not true I don't feel bad about this
yeah I mean the plantain thing I didn't
I thought it was kind of cute yeah with
your bowl of plans